so to start I guess we'll start with
this simple win for white position that
is known as building a bridge in endings
of course I should have said welcome to
the ending class just so people won our
fair where we are but you already know
so in a position like this
the win is very one-dimensional it's
very very simple but in order for this
to win hello in order for you to win you
just have to think yourself it has to
rather than just memorize the moves you
have to memorize the concept if you
memorize the concept you will always get
it right it's like when I teach it to my
students I've never had when I asked
them and then they fail because things
have to make sense
okay now the idea in this position is to
win the game if to put it in the most
primitive simplistic way is to Queen the
white pawn there's not not going to be a
checkmate attack or something you have
to Queen upon how to Queen the pawn you
have to get the King out but when you
show your king the black rook is going
to go crazy with checks check check
check check check and you will always
either threaten the pawn or threaten to
go behind the pond and stop it so the
white king is gonna be a little confined
to his pawn so just going out where the
king is not going to solve it you have
to accomplish a few things on the way to
victory one of them you have to make
sure the black king is further away from
the pawn okay that's that always has to
be the first step when the blocking is
away from the pawn he is cut off he
cannot approach the pawn in one move
which is very useful for reasons you
will see very shortly and he is not
participating that's one step the second
step is we have to use our rook for
shelter against that menacing checking
opponent Rock let's do it one button by
move I move there's more more than one
winning move in this position but I'm
just going to show you the most direct
way
so rook g1 check immediately checking
the King and you notice that the poor
King has to go further for example if he
tries to be a smart aleck and go this
way
saying I'm not going away from the
going towards the pond then he makes
life very easy for the white player by
playing this then the wind becomes
really very simple because now there's
no way to check with the rook on f2 I
would have loved to check you with the
rock but I can't and my next move is
most likely going to be e 8 equals queen
with a prozac victory so after the check
he has to go away
8 7 H it doesn't really matter we'll
play 8 7 because it's the most
challenging move now once again we can
see that if we bring the King too soon
out in this position then the rook is
going to check us and that's you try to
go out again check and you have to place
a move that defends the pawn let's try
this for example and I'm gonna check you
again and doesn't matter if you let's
say go away from the pawn then I'm going
to attack the pawn so you have to
immediately go back and guess who's also
going back the rock so you have to go
this way and then after check I'm
attacking the King and keeping an eye on
the pawn so you have to defend it and I
can check it one more time in other
words this is very unproductive all
those checks are leading nowhere so what
do you need to do you need to use your
rook as we said for a shelter so once
the King has moved we need to play the
move rook to g4 that is maybe the
hardest move in in this in winning with
a bridge why is it harder the hardest
because you wonder why am I not going to
g5 after all you will see that in many
times later on the rook might go to g5
anyways why am I losing this tempo
you're why not rook g5 the reason is
very simple you want to keep this rook
away from the black king as much as
possible head you play droop to g5 then
immediately the King would harass the
rook and that is a bit annoying if the
rook leaves the G file the king is going
to come closer if the rook stays on the
G file well what have we achieved by
playing with g5 so the long story showed
the rule comes only to g4 now black can
try one of several moves for example a
most logical move would be to play here
trying to cut the King off from one
direction so he can only go to f7 but
now white wins like so king f7
threatening to Queen the pawn Czech
threatening to Queen the pawn you gotta
check again and now I'm playing King f6
now I am NOT threatening to with two
Queen the pond but I am threatening to
create a cover as we will see in a
second so let's first see what if white
if black continues to check just like we
saw in the previous examples if you
check again this time the King goes to
e5 and I'm threatening to Queen the pawn
and after a check my rook is just in
time to cover now look how all the parts
of the equation fell into place
my King is out so the pawn is ready to
Queen my rook is being used for shelter
as a bridge in front of the black rook
and notice the black King cannot reach
the pawn in one move if this King was on
g7 then all this maneuver was worthless
because he would just trade and the King
from here comes would come here and he
just takes the pawn and he makes a
simple draw as it is the King is too far
to stop the pawn white is just winning
some of you might say okay but in this
position white is not threatening to
Queen so why must I check why can't I
just play a move for example like okay
your move well now we get the point now
the rook is gonna go to g5 neither
Brooke is gonna come one step closer in
order to provide that bridge that
shelter to the King on f5 and ef5 notice
again how this King is just useless now
if you attack my rook it's too late so
for example you can do let's say check
and I'm just going to go to e6
threatening to Queen the pawn and if you
check then guess what my rook is again
in time or if in this position again you
will try to just mark time say by
playing this move then my rook is ready
to come and interfere between the rock
and the pond after check my King has a
classic
a way to hide behind the rock very very
elegant do we all understand that do we
have any questions about the process
does anybody have any question about it
again don't memorize the moves memorize
the concept because we can move this
whole thing once one file to the left
and it'll still be fine everything moves
to the left of course the black rule
can't but everything else would move one
file to the left it'll be exactly the
same victory exactly the same kind of
win the ideas we want to Queen de pon to
clean the pond we need to get our King
out if we get the King out too soon the
rook is going to check it to death and
what's worse is gonna keep him tied to
the pawn or else he's just going to
attack the pond so step one like we said
move the King away
check him make sure that he goes we said
that the King cannot go to have six he
has to go sideways already the King was
pushed one full file to decide now we
again saw that if we play king f7 we're
going to be checked from a distance
forever and the pawn is not going to
reach the Queen square we need the
assistant of our rock and what do we do
we are going to play rook to g4 again
not rook g5 where the king is attacking
the rook and there's no time to get the
King out and now no matter what black
does if he checked us here for example
we will just go to f7 and the pawn is
going to Queen shortly if he tries to
play let's say here this time to prevent
the key from going to f7 guess what we
have another side you cannot cover both
sides now I'm quitting the pawn unless
you check me if you check me I'm just
going to go here threaten to King the
pawn and after check King f6 we have
reached exactly the same position that I
showed before and again in this position
I'm not threatening to Queen the pawn
because the rook is attacking it but I'm
threatening to bring my rook to g5 and
use it as a shelter to my king so what
did you check me and I'll just go here
ready to cover with my rock or you mark
time and then I'm playing here winning
just to give a question if the black
book started let's start from the
beginning so let's say we here you want
this book to be where here yes okay so
let's pretend for a moment I'm just
gonna play some random move and play
here see you you want you want you're
asking all you want okay in this
position then the simple solution is now
if the rook is when the rookies on the
other side where he started when he was
on a - in other words when he was here
he was ready to check on the long side
here forever sideways and also like this
vertically or horizontally when we get
to this position he is now away from
that side and therefore I can just go
rook d3 very very simple very very
simple so now in this position all I
want to do is king to d7 and Queen de
pon because now my rook is sheltering
from any checks can you see that
everybody can see that yeah so let's
pretend that the rook changes his mind
he goes back to a2 now we can just start
exactly where we left off
rook to g3 check it doesn't matter if
it's g1 g2 or g3 the King again will
have to go sideways and then rook g4 we
have exactly the same position that we
discussed before the rook is going to be
used as a sheltering bridge for the
White King to avoid the perpetual checks
of the rod is this clear for everybody
all of you have it great wonderful
has anybody covered this with you guys
there are some positions that are really
abstract their multiplication tables of
the ABCs they just must be learned must
be remembered memorized this is one of
them because this can happen a lot in a
chess game this position this is a
typical position
so if you've never seen it before I can
tell you that why to move block to move
doesn't matter it's always a win for
white this is a position that's winning
for white and you'll see why it's
important because there are further
positions we'll what the pawns are less
advanced that makes it different that
where it makes a difference so in this
position why doesn't it matter if it's
white to move or black to move because
even if it's black to move there is no
way for him to improve his position he
is his rook is completely stuck on the
last rank preventing me if you even
let's say I makes a move let's just
let's say you play here just because
it's black to move then you're gonna get
made it there's gonna lead to checkmate
so black cannot improve the position is
black to move we can make some random
move okay and then it's gonna be white
in it and of course if it's white to
move we just thought is white so how to
win okay this is this is the best way of
course it doesn't matter if the black
king is on h8 g 8 or f8 but the most
challenging is if the king is on GA then
is the toughest why because you have to
now show how to win so rook g7 oopsie
not that route g7 Chuck okay this is now
now it forces the black King to choose a
side and that's why it's the hardest
example because okay let's pretend that
the King goes here then it's easy check
check check
and winning I'm winning the rock even if
I just traded the rock I would still
Queen the pond so here I'm just winning
the rook it's even easy easier is it
understood so far very very simple okay
let's pretend that after my check the
King moves to f8 now white wins by
playing the move rook 87 a very quiet
move threatening checkmate you notice
that the black king is in dire straits
he's about to get made it if he tries to
run this way then I'm simply going to
and I'm gonna trade rocks and I'm gonna
push my pawn and of course I'm about to
Queen with an easy win very very simple
if you try to run the other way well we
have seen this before
once again we pushed upon we check the
key we'll have to go here check winning
understood
so from this starting position why to
move block to move doesn't matter always
willing for white just to mention why
isn't white playing this move some
players will say well why do I have to
check I can just go here now I'm
threatening to play f7 this move doesn't
spoil the win but it just makes it
longer because now black is not facing a
mate his rook is free and he can play
here and now we just have to repeat the
position because I I cannot push my pawn
and he is threatening to play rook takes
pawn check be careful of that so I have
to go back here threatening mate you'd
have to go here and then I'm gonna play
check well this is winning just like we
saw before it doesn't spoil the win but
it just forces us to repeat to get to
this position one more time
understood black the move white to move
same thing okay so next position we're
gonna have an almost similar position
except for
we moved everything one square to the
side like that
okay now this position and again doesn't
matter if the king is on g8 or h8 this
position is always a draw no matter
who's on the move because as you will
see there is just no way to cake to keep
this king away from the corner so again
it's we put it we block to move if it's
white to move of course it's even either
black just is gonna make some move and
say to white okay do you do do the worst
that you came to me and there's no way
to get them out
you can play check and I go to the
corner you can play check and I'm gonna
go out of the corner there is just no
way to advance no way this is just a
forced draw the only way to do it is if
black makes some terrible mistake but
the King is just gonna run between these
two squares and the rook is always going
to stand the last strength to make sure
there's no mate of course if you let me
let's pretend that you play I don't know
so move like let's say like this that
doesn't threaten mate then I can always
go all the way back even if I feel like
it and start checking the white King
forever even if you stay on the rank
it's a draw if you don't everything is
just a draw simple understood and like I
said doesn't matter if it's black to
move white to move always a draw always
but let me make a slight change in the
position and let's pretend that we add
one more pawn like this and so might say
okay what's the big difference
who cares if there's one pawn two pawns
or eight pawns on that file it looks
like you're still not going to be able
to Queen them
well not true in this position it's not
true this position is winning why is it
winning let's see if anybody can use
their imagination and tell me why do you
think this might win what is the
difference I mean at the end of the day
you can check me I mean if let's say for
example let's say black goes here and
white checks and here and checks and
here how did that help
that helped none that helped nothing
furthermore if we get to the starting
position let's say after this and let's
pretend white plays here just for the
sake of argument and black played here
and now we play check and check
here and now it looks like we're good
and ready to play rookie J Chuck and the
plan is that after Jack g6 again looks
awesome right white is ready to play
rook AJ checkmate and he's winning the
game hallelujah
except oopsie rook the exponent King
takes what do we have
stalemate
no win so from the starting position
let's say again black will play his move
rook b8 because he can't do anything but
just kill time and why would white win
well I'll explain to you white will win
because he's gonna give up one point to
trade rooks and transpose into an easily
winning King and pawn ending how does he
do that he really wants to push the Jeep
on but he knows that if he does it right
now that the black rook is gonna start
checking it and it's gonna be annoying
so first things first
rook a6 and again it doesn't matter if
the rook is on the C file the D fall or
the a file or the B file and if their
other work is over somewhere else we
play here the point is to avoid any
checks again you notice that both the
king in the rook are pretty stuck they
cannot do anything productive if you for
example go here I might even play this
with my King and I'm just gonna help
support my pawn so that's not gonna be
useful so black will mark time I'm
guessing by something like this and now
white will play the move rook f6 again
this is preparation for what's about to
come
okay let's say just for the sake of
accuracy maybe I will start with the
move
g7 oops here this is probably even
simpler so that there's no no tricks and
all just to force black to stay because
if the black rook leaves he is gonna get
made it by rotate so that's probably the
simplest yes to mark time then my row
comes to f6 oops
the mouse is refusing will insist rook
f6 again all the black pieces are tied
down the white ink
the black king cannot even make a legal
move so he's gonna have to mark time by
playing this for example and now the win
is excuse me rook f8 rook takes pawn
takes key Queen King takes King 87 and
the white pawn marches all the way to
the Queen Square winning understood okay
one more position that is from the same
family so to speak we have a position
like this so until now we saw when the
position is advanced when the King in
the corner advance one squared then it's
a win regardless of who's on the move
here it is very important who's on the
move really really important if it's
white to move here he wants to get his
King here to g6 if he got the King here
he will win in other words if black just
says well I don't have anything
productive to do let me just make a move
here in mark time that's already lost
now he lost why is why is he lost
because after King g6 we are gonna get
to that position that we just saw before
that we are familiar with there is no
way to stop the move f6 here you can
check or you can mark time to whatever
you want my next move is gonna be f6 if
you let me make you on the last length I
can do that as well if the rook leaves
the rank I'm not very picky so we know
this is already winning let's say after
here here nor even no need to even
continue right we already know that from
previous so the question is okay
therefore if it's black to move since
the right to move eno-kun g6 is gonna
win
what should black do yes
rook v6 exactly a very very important
idea to cut the king of not allow the
king to advance to the 6:9 if you play
this move against the Grandmaster
chances are that he is going to offer
you a draw because if he sees that you
know this move maybe he will try a few
more moves to drive you crazy but he
already has it in his mind that even if
you are an eight-year-old kid or a
six-year-old kid he's gonna he's not
going to beat you he knows it because
that's just a proof that you know how
not to lose this position and what is
the idea
white can just mark time with his rook
and black can do the same we can dance
like this until midnight that's no
problem eventually sooner or later in
order to try to make any progress you
will try to push the pawn but by pushing
the pawn when white is good and ready to
play king g6 he has lost his shelter now
the black guru goes all the way back to
this position and guess what now it's a
drawer the King has no place to hide
anymore after king g6 it looks like
white is just about to give checkmate
except that the rook is starting to
check and now it's just a draw no chance
to win anymore you go out I can just
check you forever even if I don't even
let's say you play here and I makes a
move with my King doesn't even matter
there's no way to make progress anymore
White has to concede that drawing this
kind of a position understood yes okay
so one more route gaining that I want to
show you which I know our friend to the
left already know you have a question
please yes
I need you to show me one second I'll
build a position is that good okay
yes no it'll be it's exactly the same
it's still it's still a win if it's
right to move and it's still a draw if
it's black tonight because if it's right
to move he wants to go here and he wins
because if you check me I'm just here
and now my threat of checkmate he forces
you to go back else you get checkmated
and then guess what the roof swings to
the other side game over no way to stop
row coming to h8 either would mate or
winning the rock that's right that's
different that is very different yes if
you can check me every time the point is
that I have to hide if I cannot use my
palm to shelter myself it's always going
to be a draw so of course here if it's
white if it's white just make a move
let's say a little bit I'm disposition
just to throw in a move and black plays
here then it's a draw now if now we can
save the game the King cannot cross the
moment the pawn pushes I'm gonna go all
the way down and checks from a district
from a distance
what you mean is like if I have a
position like this again I'll try to
build the position a little differently
if let's say my king is here and my pawn
is here and let's say my rook is here
yeah a position like this then of course
the rook is already ready to check I
mean I don't have a place to hide so by
playing a move like this it's just
useless for me because of the the check
I don't have a pawn to cover yes
no because my rook is always going to be
on the third ring so let's pretend for
example I'm gonna play some bad moves so
black just to get to that let's say
check here check here white got a lot
right
white position improved a lot but I play
here and that's it now you cannot
exactly the moment the pawn pushes he
loses the shelter and then here now I
have to tell you yeah that maybe you can
even III think well it depends again in
this position it depends when this King
is because if this King is not gonna f8
for example I think that even this is as
good enough I can just go oh it's white
remove sorry here okay and the point is
that after King here okay it's very
important to go away to the short side
to go like this and after check here and
now I have the long side my rook is
gonna check you this is a bit more
advanced I'm not touching this one today
but just to give you ideas that this is
going to be these positions at least
block has many checks on the long side
here so maybe if this is what you meant
before about the long side is that what
you were talking about before
yeah but not here that the King in this
position yes ah maybe let's take a look
lookie one it's whitey moved all right I
have to make a move for white
oh you want to make a bad move but the
question is what if I make a good man
well okay let's say here and you want to
play here right okay I know that is this
element because if King here then King
here this is the point and then if you
play here I just go down to my rank if
you play here I go back you can never
play a six this is the point so yeah so
rook you want ya in this position there
are several ways to to make a draw in
this position but this is a tricky
position but that was just to mention to
try to answer your question from before
about the long and short side up okay
okay
so one last position for Rock endings
and then we're going to go over some
porn endings let me remember how to
build this position promptly alright
let's try this position done so in the
case of a rook pawn ok this becomes of
course more tricky because the king is
cut off by the black rook and you know
we know that in order to Queen this pawn
again to win the game you have to Queen
the pawn to Queen the pawn you have to
get your king out of jail and since you
don't have an minus one file or like an
A - file then it's going to be very hard
you have to just use this you must go
somehow to the B file to get out of it
but in order to do that there is one
simple rule that you must follow the
black king must be cut off to the last
three files in other words you have to
have the King no further than the fault
that here already is already on if he is
on the a file the beef I mean if he is
on let's say here or here does no
problem here is also okay but if he
already gets to here then it's it's a
draw then it's going to be a draw so the
winning move will be to play rook oopsie
the mouse always in system like one
ranked class I like that okay here very
important to cut the King off to the
last three ranks of files the King
cannot be allowed to cross further now
why is that well you'll see that in this
position he has nothing very productive
to do you can kill time either with his
rook or with his King okay let's pretend
with this rock doesn't really matter and
white is gonna advance and black in just
kill time okay eventually we arrived at
this key
position like this okay and now you save
yourself well this was very nice the
point is one Queen one point on one
square away from becoming a queen but
how is this poor King and ago I mean I'd
love to play King somewhere there and
that's not letting me and any other
movies just illegal so how to win now we
see the purpose of cutting the king of
exactly three or fewer files we are
going to play rook c2 just in time
King me seven rook c8 and now we're
going to see two moves King b7 and King
d6 let's start with the easy one king b7
rook b8 again the timing is everything
here now I'm ready to trade rocks of
course you can't afford it and you have
no time to getting any closer to the
king if you could have brought your king
to here I could never get my king out
ever so you have to play some rook move
let's say to here away from my rock and
now King here trapped into Queen check
threatening to Queen again notice that
my broken b8 is protected one more time
I am ready to Queen and now if you check
me I am just running away
I don't need my King anymore because my
rook is supporting the Queen Square and
this is of course winning I'm
threatening to Queen if you go Luke a3
I'll just queen win the rock if you
check me more I can just go here for
example and not a row can't even stop
the pawn anymore easy right everything
came into place right in time as you can
see but one thing that we need to
discuss in this position instead of king
b7 I want to play a more challenging
move in King d6 this is a little
trickier again rook b8 r okay III king
b7 rook check now you will notice the
purpose of kinky sex the King v6 doesn't
allow the king to go to c5 so if you try
to go this way I'm going to check you
you have to go here I will check you and
guess what do not cross
my king doesn't let you cross if you try
King a5 I'm gonna go check and up see
you have to protect your pawn I'm about
to take the pawn if you go away I'll
take it so you have to go back and guess
who's going back again no good so we
have to make some change in this
position after King b6 here King b7
check we cannot go king a sex what are
we going to do we are going to go King
c8 this is still winning the good news
this is still wedding now black can
still try to pose some problems he is
gonna go rook c3 shock he has a purpose
behind this move trust me he wants to
put his king opposite the other king
well we know that if the King goes to b7
we just repeat I just checked you again
so you have to play King d8 and now he
is going to play rook oopsie again the
same story
ruk a string one more time one more time
black is trying to defend by means of
tactics if a 8th Queen white is going to
wake up to a very root chakra Group H a
checkmate and black wins well of course
we cannot afford that but white still
has a tricky maneuver again this is how
to memorize but it's just and it doesn't
happen often but it's just nice to kind
of know check very very nice now once
again the King has a dilemma where is he
going to go you know so let's say king
c5 attacking the rock and now we can
play for example well in this position I
think I can even play rook a 6 right oh
yeah you check me right yeah if I go
here this is another thing then check
and just check forever right here check
and eventually there's going to be yeah
I cannot go up so I have to go because
if I go up Chuck is gonna win the rock
so I have to go down then check then
here then whoops and the white thing now
is too far
go King here in King here so but there's
a there's still a win I promise you
after we go check here here threaten
mate check here we play this this is
very important to know and this is not
winning because now something very very
funny is going to happen either you're
gonna go one way or another way but now
we're gonna just I'm gonna be able to
hide so of course if you take a queen
with Chuck and Queen against rook
especially when the rock is here I'm
just gonna win your rook somehow - so
you have to choose between King d5 or b5
if you go let's say here then I'm
running easily with this move just ready
to Queen after you check I go here check
I go here bye-bye
the ponies queening or another try
after this to go King d5 and again a
tricky kind of move now the thing is if
I go rook c8 like the example before
then white is black is going to play
here and again we reach nowhere
so after here this time the winning move
is this now the winning movies is the
King cannot cross notice the key the
rook is saying nah I can't cross and now
if you check me I'm just gonna go here
if you go rook e8 I just attack it if
you go check I go here threatening to
Queen if you go check I go here and now
your own king is sheltering me from the
Chuck's and white is still winning now I
know this is a bit complicated and but
like I said this almost never happens
I've been playing chess I've played so
many hundreds of games
I never even came close to having king
and rook pawn versus so that's like
happens once in a million years but
again it just shows you how with fuel
you had it
and you had that ending and you had this
kind of ending did you win
are you black did you manage to draw
very good you were lucky you didn't play
me I've learned instead ah so it was
okay yeah and let me show you this is
actually worth seeing again oh I see
let's pretend that white doesn't know to
win let's pretend he goes rook here just
to show you why you must cut the king we
know that the right movies rook here in
this case we go here now it's a draw
why because let's say white advances and
we just kill time advances advances
advances and now it's too late because
you cannot when you go let's say rook to
c8 I'm just gonna go here and not let
you cross too late you cannot get there
if you try to do it the long way let's
say you try to go from here then the
problem is King d7 rook h8 King here
look here look here and the black king
is like we know already like a thorn in
the side and just doesn't let the white
king and you never it can never get me
out of here
you can play check I'll go here you can
play a check I'll go here not useful you
can try to play maybe rule here with the
point of playing rook to c2 check but
again it's not going to go far after
this let's say even if I'm pushed to
here ok so what you know with a moment
you try to show your king your face
guess who's going to come to interrupt
the party and the King well the only way
to save the pawn is basically to go back
and ok stay ok this is a really tough
ending I know but like I said just to
note that there's a web ok now we're
going to look at some point endings we
don't have a whole lot of time left but
some pointing so my first question to
you is this how many of think that they
know all the positions of King and Queen
King and pawn pawn versus King
this position is true for almost every
setup it can happen one fall to the left
or two files to the left
or one-up rank or to files to the right
or one one ranked one line down there's
only one exception that I will discuss
today but for the most part this is true
for all those positions this is what we
call King behind his pawn the white pawn
goes this way and the King is behind it
this is always a draw no matter if it's
right to move or black to move it's
always a draw
why because black will never let white
create a path for the pawn he can
advance it all the way to the last
almost the last drink but then it's
gonna be stalemate let me show you what
I mean okay let's say white plays a
waiting move because he cannot make
progress black simply we draws back
sooner or later the white king has to
show himself and then the black king
opposes him when the King the two kings
on right opposite one another with only
one square behind its called opposition
again sooner or later to make further
progress white will have to check and
the black King is just blocking the pawn
white must play here to protect it
black is playing an ambush move white
let's say he shows himself from this
direction this time opposition push the
pawn block protect the pawn and until
now you could have gotten away with
other moves but here you must play this
move you must play a waiting move and no
matter if the King shows himself from
let's say this side or this side you
will oppose it so let's say here I'll
pose and if check block protect the pawn
stalemate understood always always
always a draw in those positions always
so it doesn't matter it could be with
the pawn is the pawn could be here and
the King will be here and the other King
here that's the same thing one rank down
everything is the same okay
everybody understood done yes no yes
yes yes the best thing to do is always
do the strategy of wait block wait and
block basically it's kind of a white
white has to play a book so you kind of
wait for the King to show itself
opposition bloc and I have to tell you
in this position for example if you play
this you don't lose it's just a bad
strategy but you don't lose because even
if white gets the opposition guess what
you can still play here and after pushed
upon you can still go backwards and it's
still a draw but just to be accurate the
strategy should always be waiting after
this you should always buy your waiting
move when the King shows itself then you
oppose when the key checks you when the
white the pawn checks you you block and
wait force why to defend upon and then
you ambush when the ambush then whenever
the King is showing himself once here or
the other way doesn't matter then you
will oppose and then after the check
it'll be a stomach always a draw will
see one exception to that in a second
now we will see a different position
let's again we'll see the same King here
same kind of thing let me just get rid
of those and I'm going to put the pawn
here this time now this is different
here at the King is in front of his pawn
and well it depends how soon was on the
move it really now before it didn't
matter it would have been a draw
regardless either black would have
played the waiting move or Y would have
played a waiting move is the same here
it's very important why you have to
think about it in a logical way whoever
played the last move managed to get the
opposition in other words why if white
white last move was king to e3 if it's
black made the last move then he played
King III King e5 himself so let's
pretend it's white to move
it's very quickly gonna turn into a draw
after now it's black to move so let's
start with black to move that doesn't
matter I can just start with black if
black to move he loses why does he lose
because he has to break the opposition
he has to choose a side and the white
king is going to choose the other side
and whenever the king is going to come
here we're just gonna oppose you have to
choose the side we're gonna break like
this and the king is gonna try to bring
the pond now we just have to count move
so we always have your position for
example this would be a terrible move
now because you're just gonna play King
b7 and guess who has the opposition
black white will have to play here well
we already know when the king is in
front of his pawn it's gonna be a draw
so you can't do that but instead if you
would have just played III and let's say
the King has the opposition then you
will play E for notice the king is still
in front of his pawn who is the
opposition white so after this this and
again the black king is gonna have to
choose a side let's say he goes this way
we are going to break through the other
way he is gonna make some move let's say
here for example to prevent me from
coming with a king to here then here now
you choose a side and I'm choosing the
other side and my pawn is marching all
the way to the Queen Square this is much
much easier than you think believe me
you just have to understand in this
position that always be in control
the idea is to clear the path to the
pond and black cannot stop it no matter
what it does if you want this way if you
want let's try just to show if he goes
let's say the other way then of course
white is gonna break through on this
side and if you play here then I can
just play here no matter what you do if
you block the King I'm just gonna play
here my pawn will always give me enough
moves to gain the opposition in case the
black temporarily got it so let's say
for example black plays here then I can
play III if you try to regain their
position I'm gonna play e4 and I have
the opposition you will pick a side and
I'm gonna pick the other side and every
single time my pawn is going to Queen
is this understood yes okay now in the
case of let me just do this where it's
white to move here we have Y to move
then we see that very quickly this is
going to turn into King behind this
point which is the draw that we learned
before let's say white does this and
block immediately oppose him if white
tries to come back black comes back if
he goes this way then we go this way
sooner or later you have to push your
pawn either as one or two squares
doesn't matter and then we already know
this is the position we saw in the
beginning of the pawn exercise white
will have to do something like this
we're gonna wait show a pose until the
stalemate all the way to the stalemate
now like everything else in life okay
there is an exception and we're going to
discuss the exception right now and then
we're going to be done okay so the
exception is
when the point is on the fifth-ranked
when upon which is the fifth-ranked it
doesn't matter who is the move this is
always a win always well it's easy to
tell that if it's black to move well
we'll see it in a second as black to
move as a matter of fact I'm gonna see
it first it's important if it's black to
move it's really easy he's gonna choose
one side we're gonna go the other side
and the pawn goes in in in
okay that was child's play right that
was very easy we already know how to win
this so the question is why is it
winning even with why to move after all
it seems dark black is going to get the
opposition the problem is he is running
out of board what do I mean after king
d6 let's say he opposes and I will push
my pawn and you will play the waiting
move and I will push the pawn normally
you go backwards one move and then you
show yourself and oppose me when I show
myself but you ran out of board you have
to go out unfortunately for you and now
my King comes in and I win
do we understand so that when the pawn
is already on the fifth-ranked too late
no matter who is on the move it's always
always always a win okay and as a desert
because I knew that I would forget to
show it so I will show it to you now
just one little thing
okay if this is the position then again
if it's white to move it's very
important to give black the opportunity
to run out to the freedom so you can
Queen your pawn so if this is why to
move the right move is king a sex and
the point is of course that after this
there's this there's this there's easy
right easy easy now you might say hey
Aviv why am I not going this way I want
to win this way well the problem with
this way is that black plays the move
King a seven and this could be a
devilish trick because that's the edge
of the board and this now white better
be smart and repeat the position in
other words you should play here here
here here to repeat and then win with
this move just like I showed you why let
me show you this could be this could be
a trick when somebody doesn't know but
if you play let's say king c6 king a7
and let's pretend that you play b6
that's already a draw I'm just going to
go King here now it's a draw too late if
you play b7 I block and we have
stalemate that's one way or if you try
to play here what do we have
stalemate again exactly so you are stuck
and the same thing is to be said after
after King ace here if you go here here
and you must play king b6 to repeat the
position if you play here it's a
stalemate very good thank you very much
for your time I appreciate it